I guess this week is a writer for The
Observer The Spectator time and
standpoint he's authored two books you
can't read this book and what's left I
just read what's left and I'm thrilled
to have him here Nick Coe and welcome to
the show
so Nick I was telling you right before
we started I just read the book so all
of your thoughts in what's left are
they're right at the tip of my brain
right now and I loved it I have been so
in this regressive left thing this far
left that your hope that your whole book
is about and you saw it you saw it early
so I want to get to that but before we
start give me some of your liberal
credentials because I want people to
know that you're a lefty what because
we're gonna you know we're gonna talk
[ __ ] about the left so I want people to
know you're an actual lefty in Europe
you wouldn't call me a liberal you call
me assessments done from the Socialist
Left we for whatever its problems and
they are manifesto manifold we covered a
great length in America used to believe
in things like civil ISM in antique
fascism in feminism to an extent in
being a part of the party of progress
and used to have some idea of what's due
to the world and I gradually realized
looking around me but this was no longer
cakes as you like if you want to put it
given sort of really young Ramraj terms
really that you know I didn't let me
that's not pretty true but there was no
longer a universal left-wing message
which meant that people around the world
could say that we're oppressed and were
oppressed by hideously actually forces
left-wing resources so being in the UK
I've had a bunch of my guests have been
lefties in the UK that are that are
talking about the same issues that
you're talking about
what is going on in the UK that I think
woke you guys up to this before it was
awoken in America because really here
it's only in the last year I think that
that
liberals are waking up to what's going
on on our side yeah we've got a saying
over here Dave but whatever happens in
America happens in Britain in Europe
five years later I think who wants to
see other way around I think that really
big arguments and big battles we've had
in Britain in particular are now coming
to America you know there are the
causalities been reversed a bit um
there's been the most ferocious rounds
here which I'm pleased about because
like you know I'm polemicist on that
political animal I don't believe that
the you know being PC and nice and kind
and gentle is a way of sorting out
problems is often a way of covering them
up but there have been huge rounds in
Britain really since 9/11 in my case
since e-rock Ward's Mouse might seem
rather odd but your older viewers may
remember your factory declarant viewers
may remember the once said under saying
was any of their left-wing is used to
campaign in favor of rights for the
Kurds and Paul said owners Saddam
Hussein fascist so in my case it wasn't
9/11 it was 2003 with the Iraq war and I
said I'm thinking well you know what
happened to all that's my youth why are
why are European left is for good
reasons you know you never need a good
reason to the plenty of good reasons for
post your clever new books um but one by
why why was it there was simply no
concern for Kurds in Iraq for socialists
in the raffle trade unions in the rock
who had been until the late eighties
there'll be demos about them they'll be
participants of their support they're
kind of staring my parents home all that
kind of thing and yes what happened
there and once you start asking that
question it's very simple question who
you friends who to use old left england
land join your comrades who are you
sticking up for whatever kind of crystal
you want to be of American policy or
village policy and I'll repeat again
I'll be throughout this interview there
are always good
because of American British policy but
who are you actually supporting and then
you get some rather ugly answers and you
you find a sort of great vacuum on most
of the list there many good left wingers
but most left where a principled
ideology ought to be yeah
so you right there I mean you hit a lot
of the book so a lot of the book deals
directly with Iraq and how it woke you
up as you just said in the horrible
things that Saddam was doing and the
horrible things that the bath party was
up to so before we get into that because
I was actually surprised how much of
your journey was through Iraq but before
you do that specifically the phrase
regressive left so it was coined by
Maajid Nawaz and it's really it's really
taken off here and I'm beginning at the
beginning of the book you mentioned that
you didn't necessarily have a word for
this and you said you didn't want to get
too hung up sort of on words do you like
the phrase regressive left there's
something else here's the thing what's
left came out in 2007 and my god and I
lost jobs because of it all hell broke
loose and I published it but the reason
I didn't I met I love the phrase
aggressive lesson it's absolutely right
the reason why I do put a name to that
is this you can say very easy oh this is
just the far left people who used to be
Marxist Leninist Trotskyist Star Wars
well what have you but here's the
problem when you interrogate these
attitudes they go way way way into the
mainstream it's people who don't
consider themselves less than assault I
mean typically in prison time sources
through in America as well from what
I've seen it's people in broadcasting
it's people in universities it's people
in schools it's people in publishing
it's people who are you have to define
themselves with quite fake people but
then have a load of ideas around it back
in John Donne the terrible ideas we've
started on the far west and and this is
what grows people wild in Britain
as partners because I wasn't just
talking about some people on the fringe
all sorts of talk about people I mean
here in Britain will say BBC some people
right who never consider himself extreme
all witness in himself moderates a
neutral I said look these ideas that
began on on the far left that it's okay
to go along with a themes and movements
that want to subtitle women kill all
homosexuals kill will Jews kill any
Muslim who of his or her own free will
decides to change their religion law yes
aside there is no God there is no ala at
all you're giving along with all of this
it wouldn't matter if it was get six
free what matters is this is permeating
the whole liberal spectrum and that's
what great people yes
so to me that was so obviously true and
it seems to be true about American
learns as well yeah so you hit on a lot
there so partly it seems to me that it's
a little bit like the phrase you know
the road the road to hell is paved with
good intentions that these people and I
think you hit on this a bunch that these
people they they have good intentions in
that they don't want extra war and we
have had a ridiculous both of our
countries right you in the UK immune
America we've right who we have had
plenty of ridiculous unnecessary Wars
we've done all kinds of things drone
strikes all of these things that we on
the Left are not thrilled with but you
make a really good argument for what is
the alternative that we basically just
give up on all of these people that live
under these horrible theocracies and
that's what put these people in the far
left in bed with some really terrible
people
yes it's also Dave yeah all all if you
get a time machine again into the future
say 50 years into the future if there
are bound to be all kinds of ideas as
our accept is there are guests on the
fringes of American society at the
moment don't you all your great pan
games
in the media Time magazine New York
Times barely even think about will be
the common sense of their age their
applies to bad ideas as well as good
ideas a really bad idea started on the
far left I would even say it wasn't even
left-wing at all after the collapse of
communism after the end of socialism
remember socialism defines what it means
to be a left-winger for a good hundred
years you know the 1880s through the
nineteen eighties then that all goes
then suddenly there are all these people
I mean Noam Chomsky is a classic example
to me who have that same spirit that no
longer have an ideology they can believe
in and so what do they do they start
just send will anyone who is against the
West can't be all bad
anyone who's against the West it has to
be the West's fault
we are the root cause to use a a phrase
that's been repeated to death and then
you suddenly find people who call
themselves new radicals or progressives
or socialists we can feminists in going
along with movements we saw an t
progressive anti-socialist aunty radical
anti women anti-gay anti-semitic and see
everything aunty liberal in the classic
turn actually movement sort of stepped
out of a liberal nightmare have you look
at their effects but because they're
anti West that's all what matters it's
because there's no longer a positive
program for being in left-wing they just
seize on anybody who is against America
against to use Sarah rather contentious
than we can have knowledge about we want
later against imperialism and that that
just starts on the extremes like good
ideas start on fringes and it comes into
the mainstream now that's not wholly the
faulty mates with liberals you know
never let your celebrity books off the
hall never let our leaders off the ball
yeah past week is a perfectly possible
reaction Lewis also terrible and not
just in you know in poor countries what
about people in America what about some
there are people in Britain what about
people in my country Muslim women are
now being told we got ghost
well he's a free moving in the free
country no second-class citizen so you
don't have to have a some some
theocratic legal system saying your
evidence worth right but how will you as
a white guy say that then people go
bananas and you're pushing your views on
them yeah even though if you're you're
the one that's abiding the laws of your
country which is what they're governed
by well now I'm afraid we'll also my
country is slightly worse than that in
that you know there's a danger we're not
quite there yet
we'll have parallel legal systems yeah
we'll have a system that in civil cases
divorce cases big deals a Muslim woman
will seems quite contentment sake we can
settle this in a Sharia Court but this
is this is kind of racist is it not if
you say to a white woman you have to go
to the court where evidence worth half
of that for the man you know right all
liberal opinion across Britain across
America across the world will go wild
this is sexism and softness is
patriarchy but it's okay when it happens
to a brown skinned woman in the name of
liberalism we are we are creating the
classic double standard of pre liberal
days as you know white people have more
rights than white people have more rice
and brown skinned people yeah
so this is not just an issue for how
people are treated in Saudi Arabia or
Iran or any other country with a also
reacts for me I would say and fear
classic legal system it's here now and
our societies yeah it does seem to be
that liberals ought to decide what type
of liberalism they believe in do they
believe in liberalism means we've all
rights we can universal values or does
liberalism mean well there's one law for
one group on one law for another group
depending on their culture does part of
this seem to you that it's just the end
game this is the end result of identity
politics we're going through right now
in America this really strong phase with
identity politics right so we're all
divided on on sexuality and
race and just every anything that you
can divide people on were divided on it
right now
and is part of this just that you saw
the end game of all of this sort of
before we did gods or Bibles or carranza
tabloids or any of that so yeah to me
there there is a big big vacuum opened
up at the end of the twentieth century
we're first of all as I said before it
may not mean so much to you in America
how big in Europe and a lot of the world
the collapse of socialism the collapse
in the belief of off the planned economy
of nationalized society but also the
collapse of a kind of not collapse but a
marginalizing of liberal optimism little
optimism just says that look the
universal human rights doesn't matter
what your skin color is you know it
doesn't matter what your religion is you
can't say oh it's my culture to oppress
women you can't it ignored laughing you
right and actually no they don't laugh
of you and that allows identity politics
which sounds fine
which sounds fine you know I got it yeah
I read these reports of black students
at Yale and you think about history of
black oppression in America and you can
understand them less it's kids they go a
bit nuts but identity politics had and
you think well you know okay let them
have their their thoughts by identity
politics has a hugely dark side because
you have no answer when the people who
say we are lost as for your identity we
are community leaders we are the mothers
well a rabbis we are the priests we
control this group this block and we say
you're part of our group our block our
community and we we say that you don't
have the same rights as a yeah a white
anglo-saxon woman at Yale we say you
know the Constitution the Bill of Rights
doesn't apply to you it's it's against
your culture and that hasn't been fought
through at all right so we split people
into into these little boxes but then
what we end up carrying the least about
is the people that are in the smaller
boxes within those boxes well uh
as largely in the world society you
mentioned earlier markeith has this one
on the wall phrase what about minorities
within minorities you know what about
what about liberals and dissidents or
free thinkers the blasphemers the women
the gays the people who say what the
hell well hell I am NOT this group I'm
not a Muslim or a Jew or whatever I'm
American right and that to me is the the
the ultimate irony here is that the the
spectrum of people that I've brought on
the show and that now I've connected
with on on Twitter or wherever it is is
I'm not judging any of these people
based on their color or their religion
or their ethnicity I'm basing it on
their ideas which we are which is the
most liberal idea yeah well actually
miss individuals very very politics is
this is when you stop treating people as
individuals you kind of identity
politics this is is is is is it is a
slippery treacherous conjunction is you
cannot have identity or you can have
politics politics means you don't just
look at people and say there's a block
in this instance what we talk about the
Muslims what I mean there's a group
called the Muslims because when you say
that you normally end up handing over
the right to speak to these Muslims
without asking admission to the most
reactionary people in it the people who
who want to enforce a communal identity
and want to enforce it first of all you
know I know there's all this paranoia
going around after the Paris attacks and
those awful events in California but
first and foremost want to enforce it on
their own kind on their tribe in
falsetto boos on them to keep them down
and the worst budget is I think
particularly bad in Britain in America
because we have this identity politics
multicultural
problem that you've had is well you know
what about the men the women who sale
the second this guy who says a community
leader doesn't represent me I've never
voted for it I don't and agree with him
what about this man who says he's a
priest the rabbi and mullah you know I
don't believe in all this crap oh I need
partially believe in it well I believe
in bits of it but you you then start
treating me as if this guy owns me
called is this group owns me without my
permission that that is that is the huge
weakness today's it's well an awful lot
before we go on to great questions on
you with a sound of your right with
Assyria you know what we gonna do about
Islamic state
it's where everyday cruelty happens in
our society it's where men and women who
need a confident liberalism liberalism
that believes in human rights liberalism
that says well actually we're not going
to say that what matters first and
foremost about you is your color or
creed they need them to help them and
they turn around to the very people who
ought to be able to help them and
they're not there in fact they're on the
other side